the table below shows the number of
chicken sold by four friends from
January to March except one entry is
missing what number should go in the
empty cell so let's see this is the
empty cell right over here they haven't
filled out how many let's see this is
chicken soul so we don't know how many
chickens Michael sold in March but we
know how many he sold in January in
February and we also know the total he
sold in the three months so he sold a
combined four plus six he sold ten in
January in February he sold ten in
January in February and we know he told
he sold a total of eleven so this 11 is
really the sum of these three right over
here so this right over here in March
has got to be one he has got to have
sold one chicken because we see four
plus six plus one is 11 let's check our
answer there we go let's try this one so
here's the missing cell and so once
again we just need to look at the total
the total is 107 so these four numbers
right over here and one is missing need
to add up to be 107 for the solar panel
installations in Wyoming so let's see 32
plus 27 is 59 59 59 plus 26 is see
seventy-nine it is 85 so these three add
up to 85 but they're missing this one
right over here so this is going to have
to be whatever 107 is minus eighty-five
so that is 22 22 solar panels in q3
because if 22 is here 22 plus this this
and this should be equal to 107 so we're
missing how many points gabriela scores
in the first quarter right over here
once again we know that she scores 35
points in the game and the other three
quarter she combined she scores a
combined let's see 10 plus 10 plus 8 is
28 points so she's 28 and the other
three quarters and she gets to 35 35-28
is she must have scored seven points in
the first quarter seven points let's do
one more so an alabama how many solar
panel installations in the fourth
quarter see 33
+ 26 is 59 plus 21 is 80 so to get from
80 to 101 we need to get another 21 sold
in the fourth quarter we got it right